je n'aurais pas cru ont cerné peut-on
sur moi réel qui est là fax du mois' me
manquait souvent de ma collègue parce
que je lui disais tu n'as plus besoin de
ce code postal on a internet dire que
roux c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on est
vraiment dépendant de l'informatique
puis surtout on a l'impression de
régresser pour brut je vous emmène à
angers où une cyberattaque paralyse
depuis plusieurs jours les sites web et
les services de la mairie
là je suis dans le hall du public il n'y
a plus aucun ordinateur qui marche il
n'y a plus aucun écran allumé par mesure
de sécurité
les employés ne doivent plus utiliser
leur ordinateur donc c'est un retour au
papier et au crayon ici plus
d'informatique on a plus que le
téléphone et puis d'appeler
l'informatique plus d'internet on a
ressorti le code postal de 1989 qui va
nous permettre d'avoir toutes les
collectivités de france avec leur code
postal pour leur adresser à nos
courriers et qu'on fait maintenant
manuscrits multiplie par deux voire par
trois tout ce que l'on doit faire
puisqu'il faut tout faire les manières
myskreen donc on écrit on équipe donc on
tourne à par demi-journée sur les postes
parce que c'est beaucoup plus fastidieux
dans l'ascenseur il ya n'affiche c'est
écrit n'ouvrait pas vos ordinateurs
c'est lundi matin une cyber attaque a eu
lieu ce week end et endommagent tout
notre système d'information côté le pire
qui pourrait nous arriver ce serait
perdre d'électricité c'est à dire que
non plus on est plus les ascenseurs la
lumière etc
pour le reste on est en mode extrêmement
dégradée où chacun fait un peu ce qu'il
veut
voilà ce qui nous relie à l'extérieur
alors qu'il est on n'avait pourtant
guère débat sur le fait de savoir si ça
va les coûts de conserver ce fax et puis
on s'était dit que si jamais ça pouvait
toujours servir mais je ne pensais pas
qu on en aurait dû usage en début
d'année 2021 il sert typiquement comme
il ya air a envoyé le dépôt de plainte
au procureur de manière à ce qu'il
arrive en temps réel a recommandé au
lieu d'envoyer quelqu'un pour le porter
la cyberattaque a lieu dans la nuit du
vendredi 16 janvier au samedi 17 janvier
d'abord cette compte twitter personnel
du maire qu'elle était piraté et ensuite
une attaque d'une plus grande ampleur
avisé les services informatiques et
numériques de la mérite les gens entrent
dans notre système
pour dire les choses de manière simple
et chiffres crypte des fichiers qui
normalement et est accessible rendant
inutilisables toute une partie de
l'architecturé de notre de notre système
informatique
il ya plusieurs types de cyber attaques
qui sont encore une fois généralement le
fait de mafia très bien organisée
parfois il s'agit effectivement de ce
qu'on appelle des rançonnage donc en
clair en crypte vos données ou bien on
utilise vos données et puis on vous
propose de vous les rendre contre une
contre une rançon
évidemment personne n'entre dans ce dans
ce jeu-là ce stade
on n'est pas en mesure de vous dire
c'est effectivement une demande de
rançon sera associé à cette cyber
attaque comme nous le savons pas
aujourd'hui si effectivement tout cas
nous n'avons pas la preuve que nos
données ont été ont été extraites d'un
système d'information l'impact de la
cyberattaque dépasse le simple cadre de
la mairie par exemple samedi la
bibliothèque a dû fermer puisque la base
de données n'étaient plus accessibles
plupart des services concrets se
poursuit on n'a pas arrêté la collecte
des ordures ménagères ou continuer à
alimenter en eau les robinets des trois
cent mille habitants de l'agglomération
en revanche nous n'avons plus depuis ce
week-end la capacité à pouvoir produire
de manière normale
le suivi de nos missions administratives
en clair on peut pas délivrer par
exemple un extrait d'acte de naissance à
quelqu'un qui viendrait le chercher en
mairie puisqu'on n'a pas accès et n'est
même pas les ordinateurs donc on n'a pas
accès à ces fichiers en gêné par la
première municipalité à connaître ce
genre de cyberattaques vincennes la
rochelle ou encore marseille ont connu
des attaques en 2001 en france ces 26
l'agencé nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information qui lutte contre
ces attaques
b le samedi matin la mairie d'angers
s'est rapproché de l'ansea amené 50
opérations en 2019 et 200 en 2020 ça
veut dire qu en une seule année
le nombre de victimes de cyberattaque a
été multiplié par quatre celle ci vise
aussi bien les institutions publiques
que les entreprises privées le poids de
l'informatique dans la vie quotidienne
des services publics n'a pas cessé
d'augmenter et on nous encourage à ça le
coc vide avec toutes les procédures à
distance avec le télétravail il l'a fait
qu'on a continué à mettre sur nos
serveurs des fonctionnalités qui
autrefois n'existait pas et on s'est
beaucoup plus concentré sur le fait
d'augmenter les services on offrait à la
population via le numérique
coffey de protéger l'architecturé c'est
si ça veut pas dire qu'on a rien fait ça
veut dire qu'on n'a pas mis assez
d'intensité et a cédé fort là dessus